(audience applauds)
Please welcome
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
(bright music)
(audience cheer)
What's up, bro?
(audience cheers and applauds)
How are you?
I'm so honored to see you.
And thank you so much for coming to the show.
It's a pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
I mean, my goodness.
Your career is as red hot as it gets.
Oh.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much, I appreciate you.
But is it true that your acting career started as a dare?
A little bit, yeah.
Tell me.
I was in college,
my freshman year at college and I'm on the track team,
and it was like, they put the freshmen on the stage
and say "Entertain us".
And I go out and I started doing impersonations
of all the coaches.
And we had a lot of characters on our, you know,
on the coaching squad and I'm doing this
just complete improv
and everybody is just cracking up and just laughing.
And I didn't think anything of it.
It was, you know, it was fun, but the next day at practice,
they were still talking about it.
And my dude, JP, he says,
he says, "Dude, you should take a theater class.
It's just like recess."
I'm like, "Oh, for real?"
And, and then I took the class,
just sort of on a dare, you know?
And the rest was me sort of tiptoeing around it
until I found the opportunity to do it.
And it's been good.
Once I chose acting, it just chose me back.
You're in Aquaman.
You've shot Aquaman 2, right?
I have shot Aquaman 2, yeah.
We shot that out in London last year.
What you wanna know?
I see-
Anything!
(Yahya laughs)
Know Jason Momoa's water, Mananalu-
Yeah, I was-
Is the official water of our show.
Is that right?
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
There we go.
I literally like, it's my favorite water
if you put it in the refrigerator,
'cause it's in a metal can, it's like a spa.
It's so nice too, 'cause you can like,
because of the metal can, it gets cold.
You can put it like, on the back,
or the neck and things like that.
So it has like dual purpose, you can reuse it.
And I think Jason,
'cause he has woken a lot of people up with his plight.
No, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean we had a no plastic rule on set.
Yep.
So shout out to Jason for that.
What is the most exciting thing to look forward to,
or any weird fly-on-the-wall for Aquaman 2?
The bad guys get to have a lot of fun in this one.
You know, I wanted to,
I wanted to break some things,
I wanted to cause a lot of problems
and it's gonna be exciting.
Okay, so I saw "Ambulance" yesterday.
Okay, how were you doing after that?
I needed Valium afterwards.
(Yahya laughs)
Michael Bay.
I really have to give it up to him.
I don't know how you pump adrenaline
into someone for two hours and 16 minutes straight.
Yeah.
It never lets up.
It starts at word go.
Yeah.
I cried in one of the first scenes,
'cause I have daughters.
Okay.
So I freaked out.
Yeah.
My God, am I just so captivated by you.
I appreciate that.
As I think we all are.
How did you approach this?
Like you're working on a Michael Bay movie.
He's bringing his A-game.
The film is like, what does Jake say?
He says, "You'll come for", he says,
"You'll pay for your seat but you'll only need the edge."
You know what I mean?
It's just like, it's a adrenaline ride.
It's a thriller.
And to work with Michael, you just really gotta be game.
You just gotta say it's a yes endgame.
So if you're thinking too much,
you'll get lost in it, you know.
You don't want to get passed up.
I've seen so many of his movies
and I feel like this one, for me, might be my favorite.
Is that right?
Yes.
And everything in this film pays off so well.
Oh, I'm glad to hear that.
I'm glad-
It's so good.
I think it's gonna be so huge.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
But you're so good in it.
(Yahya chuckles)
I mean, I can see why every film you're doing
is like big and you're crushing,
and you're just on top of the world.
You are so captivating and so talented.
Oh, thank you very much.
(bright music)